On the season finale of Rick and Morty
dr. Wong had a cancellation today
anybody up for a family session I am
actually disintegrating.
It's the invisibility belt
He grazed them, thanks Morty! Why should I let
you use it you never let me use it. Can I
have the belt it would really piss off morty.
Fantastic Idea.
Looks like yout two have to fight about why you can't control your kids. Good thing
dr. Wong's got an opening, bye!
I think that was just somebody saying what if
Rick did a planet. A question that everybody
wants to know obviously who knows who
said that someone who didn't want to
work that day but the answer was I don't
know what if he did okay get right into
it
this jaw drop what the heck is that what
this show is very weird very strange but
the theme is actually parenting we are
going camping there's trees over there
we're on solid ground I don't know how
often the whole family is together but
this sitcom tropy concept of them just
going camping felt really good to me
Jerry tried to people respect family
member finally and camping is something
that Jerry would be good at because it's
basically like being homeless
that's the camping spirit with Beth I
wanted to see her with a construction
hat on like like next to her dad talking
shop why are the athletes going through
the introvert second obviously so they
can bully the mathematicians and give us
astronomer irony is Beth right to take
care of Rick's kids but her kids are a
of her sight you know the Acorn doesn't
fall that far from the tree you my
little steampunk overlord
Then suddenly, Rick's girlfriends man pops-up
Rick has said he's a god many times so
it was really exciting to see two gods
getting a fist fight I wrote this as a
parking lot fight between two dads at
like a softball game
you wanna go bro I love what we're
learning about Rick not a good dad but
he's so petty he'd rather just fight
through that then let his daughter down
keep the city okay my daughter and I
built that thing it's important to her
kids come in save the day important
story for the kids they got taken away
from Spring Break so what did they do
they made their own Spring Break
I won't encourage all the kids to do but who am I to say?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 10 trailer video for the finale
that's right last episode of season 4 so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will
talk about what's going on with the
season 5 episodes because Dan Justin and
a bunch of the other cast members have
talked about season 5 quite a bit the
last month dan and Justin have also been
hyping up that there's supposed to be
some major canonical serialized story
element during the episode if you felt
like they've been doing a lot of one-off
episodes during season 4 apparently
during the finale there will be some
major serialized element that's going to be
a big season 5 teaser so I'll talk about
that during the video too the title of the
episode is star morte Rick turn of the
Jerry which is a Star Wars Return of the
Jedi reference so even if the title
doesn't have a ton to do with the actual
plot of the episode as has been the case
with a lot of the episodes this season
they will probably be at least a few
major Star Wars references but the
trailer itself actually seems like it's
taken from the cold opening scene where
Beth wants to go back to see dr. Wong
the therapist from pickle Rick in season
3 with the family dr. Wong has an
opening and because Rick hates going to
therapy instead of turning himself into
a pickle this time to get out of it he
pretends that he's dying be a
disintegration but I don't expect that
they got Susan Sarandon to actually come
back and do the voice of dr. Wong again
so either they never show any scenes
with dr. Wong or one of the family
members actually goes to see her and
they just do it off-screen or she just
shows up in the background and doesn't
speak or is just a bit purely for a cold
open scene that they never follow up on
during the episode
Dan and Justin made a whole big thing
about not rushing to go back to old
story lines or characters and because of
what they did during Episode six with
all the overloaded fanservice faked
storylines it raises a lot of questions
about how they're going to handle their
ongoing serialized story elements from
previous episodes but Morty immediately
sells Rick out knowing that he's using
an invisibility belt not because he's
trying to get revenge on Rick for
selling him and summer out in Episode
nine when he specifically said that he
wouldn't do that apparently he just
pissed because Rick won't ever let him
use the invisibility belt you know the
only thing that Morty would use that for
is just peeping on Jessica
one of the first things he did with the
reality switching promote a couple
episodes ago was to use it to walk into
the girls locker room at school to try
and catch them naked the funnier thing
about that scene wasn't that he actually
went into the locker room you kind of
expect him to do crazy stuff like that
it was the look on his face when he
walked out he did not look happy or
satisfied at all
zoom and enhance he actually looks
deeply disturbed and concerned so you
can only imagine what it was he actually
saw in that locker room
something terrible apparently some of
you that probably noticed how much the
season four episodes and scenes like
this feel like they're trying to rehash
the dynamics of season 1 and season 2
with the family members at each other's
throats but still staying together as a
family unit that's actually mostly on
purpose Danna Justin said after season 3
with the divorce storyline and the
family being split up with Gerry in his
apartment and Rick taking total control
of the family they wanted to reset the
show to be more like it was during
season 1 and season 2 where Rick is
still this very doctor who style a
character with near infinite power and
intellect but somehow Beth is still head
of the household and even though she
kind of presents Gerry for being so
worthless she still wants to stay
married to him but slowly each of the
family members personalities start to
evolve within that dynamic like Morty
becoming more of a cocky Morty shout out
to season 1 a cocky Morty is a dangerous
thing a cocky Morty can lead to some big
problems can be a real bad thing for
everybody oh yeah how's that
I'll explain when you're older that's
recognizes that she's just like Rick and
searched to come to terms with that the
Apple does not fall far from the tree
she's also kind of a bad parent in last
week's episode too because she gets so
caught up creating this other
civilization with Rick which is exactly
why she was getting upset with Rick at
the beginning of the episode and you
even have a giri that's slowly starting
to realize that he's an idiot becoming
more self-aware and slowly trying to
change that even though he's still at
the bottom of the totem pole they don't
completely reset their dynamics at the
beginning of every new episode like The
Simpsons but it's a close comparison I
know a lot of people are like please
don't turn this show into the Simpsons
because of what happened to that show in
the later seasons but a really good
example is like Morty's never going to stop
being 14 except when he gets visions of
possible futures like season 4 episode 1
where he's seeing his potential futures
but he's not actually going to grow up
every single episode and get older and
older and older until he's an old man by
the end of the series as for the big
season 5 teaser that Dan and Justin kept
talking about since last summer at Comic
Con normally their tradition of the
season finales have been to have a mr.
poopy butthole post credit scene tag
commenting on the season as a whole and
bookending everything then reminding
fans that it's going to be forever
until you get a new season of episodes
those have mostly been meta jokes about
their laps production cycle in the past
behind the scenes and their ability to
actually get episodes out in a
predictable schedule but to be fair they
were not wrong when they babe ruth's
style called their shot and said I might
have a big white Santa Claus beard they
did wind up dropping episodes at the end
of the year and they even had an episode
set during the Christmas holiday even
though all the episodes aired before the
Christmas holiday militias crossed her
fingers and prayed that he doesn't come
out and say that there's not going to be
new episodes for a long long time but
normally when Dan and Justin talked
about doing major canonical serialized
story episodes in the past that's been
related to evil Morty who kind of became
their most popular alternate version of
Morty the problem with them doing that
though and this gets back to the events
of episode 6 with the story train they
already did a major evil Morty Citadel
of Rick's scene and it was so
over-the-top ridiculous fanservice as
part of that larger Jesus deus ex
machina scene in their commentary about
things that Rick and Morty as a show
would never do it kind of feels like
they were doing that as a way to say
that they didn't have any
huge plans to do more evil Morty Citadel
stuff anytime soon there was a post
credit scene tag during the first half
of season 4 with them sitting on the
rooftop talking about a storm coming in
and it felt very metaphorical and
ominous like something terrible is
coming for them later this season and if
we're talking about Return of the Jedi
Star Wars references because of the
title of the episode you think Emperor
Palpatine and even though it kind of
seems like evil Morty had his own evil
emperor poopy butthole with him based on
the show's dynamics unless there's some
character that we don't know is behind
evil Morty evil Morty himself would be
the Emperor in this scenario part of me
also thinks this emperor poopy butthole
was just there's a joke just to create
more merch for them to sell and make
money on we'll just see what happens
I'll keep doing Rick and Morty videos
during the off-season while we wait for
new episodes so I will add any big
season 5 updates to those when we get
them but leave all your video requests
in the comments in my full season 4
episode 10 video will post next Monday
just like normal so as long as you have
alerts enable for my channel you should
see those videos when they post
congratulations Stefan Dalton you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Rick &
Morty video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details and for those of you that are
really bummed out that we haven't had a
lot of movies or a lot of really big TV
premieres in the last couple of months
because of the virus that's going to change
the second half of the year most of all
the stuff that got delayed earlier is
coming the second half of the year so
everyone click here for all my full Rick
and Morty season 4 episode videos and
click here for my brand new Black Adam
teaser in Justice Society breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!